Yeah,
so I want to tell you,
I'm going to make an a little
announcement first.
I'm going to do a series of lectures,
I think starting in May,
maybe at the Isabel Bader theater.
We're trying to look into booking that
on.
I'm going to do a psychological
interpretation of the Bible from
beginning to end.
That's the plan anyway,
so I'm going to do that once a week.
So if you're interested in,
in that,
I would recommend that you men,
maybe you're not and that's fine
obviously,
but if you go onto my twitter account,
you could just,
there's a place you can sign up.
It doesn't mean that you'll attend.
I'm just trying to see if there are
people who are interested in.
I'd been interested in doing that for a
long time and so I think I'm going to
try it.
So anyways,
that's the announcement then.
Sad about it.
I guess so.
Okay.
So look,
we're going to switch gears today.
Um,
the first half of this course as you've
no doubt already gathered is because
it's round grounded essentially in
clinical theories of personality.
It tends more towards the philosophical
and I told you that the reason for that
was that I regard clinical psychology as
a branch of engineering rather than a
branch of science.
It's human engineering obviously,
and because of that it's an applied
science and so that means it straddles
the ground between a science and a
practice and it and because it's.
It involves human beings.
It necessarily involves value because we
live inside value structures and so the
logical consequence of that is that
investigation into the philosophy of
value is necessary in order to
understand clinical psychological
theories.
Because really what you're trying to do
as a clinician,
you could say you're trying to do two
things.
One is to help people have less terrible
lives,
but you're also trying to help them have
better lives and there's obviously a
value structure that's inherent in that
attempt because you're moving from
something of less value to something of
more value and so and it's best to just
face that and all the complexities that
come along with that head on.
Now.
I think what you do as a clinician to
overcome whatever tendency you might
have to impose your value structure on
someone is you do an awful lot of
listening and so my basic practice with
people is to say to them,
well,
obviously you're here because you would
like things to be better,
but that's okay.
We can use your definition of what
constitutes better.
constitutes worse at air or we can
establish that through dialogue and
negotiation.
What are you aiming at?
How would you like things to be better a
year from now safe?
If you could have what you wanted?
If your life was put together,
what would that look like and you can
have a very straightforward discussion
with people about that.
If you're not trying to cram the way
that are orienting the world into your
particular perspective.
Now that's one of the dangers of being
the adherent of a psychological school.
Now,
having said that,
it's also there was research done many
years ago showing that if you are an
eclectic psychotherapists best,
which means that you sort of picked and
chose from different psychotherapeutic
schools.
You tended to not be as effective as you
were if you were the dedicated adherent
of a given school.
And I think the reason for that is that
there's so many schools have
psychological thought that if you say
that you pick and choose from all of
them.
What that really means is that you don't
know anything about any of them.
And then there's also the additional
factor maybe might call it that.
If someone comes to you and they're very
chaotic and confused,
helping them impose any structure onto
their life is likely to be an
improvement over no structure at all.
And you could think about that in a pig,
Eddie and sense is that you know you're
going to be happier playing a game
rather than no game.
And there's many games that you could
play that are better than no game.
And so if you go to a therapist that has
a particular viewpoint and they help you
structure your understanding of the
world within the confines of a given
clinical model and you came in,
they're very chaotic and uncertain,
then maybe that's going to be a lot
better for you than just floundering.
And I,
and I think there's some real truth in
that.
And I think that that's part and parcel
of the same,
uh,
of another,
what you might call it,
reasonable observation about maturation,
is that it's very necessary for people
at some point in their life to dedicate
themselves to a single game of some
sort,
which is kind of what you're doing in
university.
You know,
you have to become one thing at some
point in your life.
And the sacrifice of course,
is that you give up all the other things
that you could become.
But the,
you don't really have a choice because
if you don't decide voluntarily to
become one thing,
you know,
to become a disciplined adherents of
some specific,
uh,
practice or profession or viewpoint,
then you risk just aging chaotically and
you,
you don't get away with not aging.
So you might as well age into something
that's,
that's actually something rather than
just remaining or then just becoming an
old child,
which is really not a,
not a good thing.
It's not a good thing to see.
Especially by the time people hit about
40.
It's not,
it's not,
it's not pretty for them or anyone else.
And even at 30,
it's getting pretty old at that point.
40.
It's like it's almost a repairable at
And the reason for that is you run and
you start running out of opportunities
when you're young and stupid.
People don't care because they think,
well,
you know,
whatever,
you've got decades of,
of,
of possibility still ready to unfold in
you.
But if you're in the same unspecified
position at 40,
people are much less forgiving.
Especially because if they're going to
hire someone who doesn't know what's
going on or or employ them or or sorry
or engage them in some sort of
productive activity,
they might as well take a chance on
someone young and full of potential
rather than someone who's really lived
more than half of their life already
because of course you have by the time
you're 40 more that.
Okay,
so so anyway,
so that's with regards to putting the
first half of the course to bed,
so to speak.
The second half is more more scientific
and there's a bit of a gap that,
and it's a gap I'm trying to resolve
conceptually because now we move into
more biological models and into models
that are psychometric and psychometrics
is the psychological study or the study
of psychological measurement and now if
you're a scientist,
you're.
There's a couple of things that you're
obliged to do if you're a scientist.
One is to utilize the scientific method.
That's usually the experimental method
where you take two groups randomly
selected,
apply a manipulation to one of them and
not an equivalent manipulation of a
different source to another.
Hypothesize about what the outcome is
likely to be and then test it.
Uh,
that's,
that's the technical experimental model
anyways.
You're also obliged as a scientist to
come up with a measurement of your,
of your,
uh,
to come up with a measurement.
Let's just put it that way.
That's reliable and valid.
Okay.
And what a reliable measure is one that
measures the same way across multiple
measurements.
So for example,
you wouldn't want to take a ruler that's
made out of flexible rubber to measure
things with because it wouldn't give you
the same measurement if you put it in
different situations.
That's reliability and it's a term you
need to know.
It means that the measurement tool
produces stable results across different
instances of the measurement.
Without that,
you don't have a measurement.
The other critical
factor with regards to a measurement is
that it has to be valid,
which means that it actually has to
measure what it purports to measure and
it has to be usable for an array of
different purposes as a consequence.
And so you might think,
well,
the purpose of scientific endeavor is to
predict and to control.
You could say understand,
predict,
and control,
but understanding prediction and
controls are all manifestations of the
same underlying
thoroughly designed comprehension.
Now,
here's what's happened with the
measurement of personality.
It's a funny story in some sense,
a peculiar story because
in many ways what we've come to
understand about personality from a
scientific perspective developed in a
very atheoretical manner.
It's not very common in scientific
endeavor that that occurs is that what
we know about personality emerged from,
I would say statistically rigorous
observation without it being the
consequence of any real model.
So often what happens in scientific
endeavor is that someone generates a
model first,
a theoretical understanding,
and then they generate measurement tools
based on that theoretical understanding
and then they test the measurement tools
to see if all of the measurement tools
perform and if they fail,
at least to invalidate the underlying
theory.
That isn't what happened with
psychometrics,
what except in a loose way.
So here's the loose theory and you've
got to get this exactly right to
understand this property.
You've got to get it exactly right and
it's really important because in so far
as you guys are interested in
psychology,
especially in the experimental end of
measurement is everything and so much of
what psychologists publish and write
about is incorrect and the reason it's
incorrect is because they do not have
their measurements properly instantiate
it.
It's a massive problem.
Especially in social psychology.
In fact,
it's probably a fatal problem in that
most of the things that social
psychologists measure don't exist and in
social psychology has been rife with
scandals for the last four or five years
and and there's good reason for it,
but a big part of the problem is is that
the measurement that people are not
stringent and careful enough about their
measurements.
So we're gonna walk through this very,
very carefully.
So I'm going to set forward a set of
propositions and you have to think about
them because each of them are there
axiomatic.
So you sort of have to accept them
before you go onto the next step.
And there's certainly room to question
them.
But here's the bare bones of the
psychometric of model of personality,
so we'll call it roughly the big five
model and the reason it's called the big
five model is because the psychometric
investigations have indicated that you
can specify human personality along five
basic dimensions.
You might ask,
well,
what exactly is personality?
And while that's partly what we've been
trying to wrestle with the entire course
so far,
and I would say,
or what exactly is a trait?
Think of a trait has an element of
personality.
And I think the best way to think about
a trait is as a subpersonality,
so you're,
you're made up of sub personalities that
are integrated into something vaguely
resembling a unity.
But the unity is,
is diverse.
There are,
there are,
there are describable stable elements
that characterize you,
that are elements of your being.
So for example,
here's,
here's some common ones I might say,
well,
are you social or,
or would you rather be alone?
So,
uh,
here's,
here's a good question for you to
define.
Decide whether you're extroverted or
introverted.
It's pretty straightforward because
that's,
that's the first major dimension.
Basically,
if you take any set of questions about
any,
any set of questions that could be
applied descriptively to a human being
and you subject them to a statistical
process called factor analysis,
you can determine how they grouped
together.
So what I would be interested in,
let's say I asked you 100 questions,
let's say asked 100 questions of you and
a hundred other people.
What I would find was that reliably,
if some person answered question a say
on a scale of one to seven,
six or seven,
there would be other questions in the
set of questions that they also tended
to answer on the upper end of the scale
or reliably if they answered one
question at the top of the scale data
answer another question at the bottom
that's a pattern of covariation.
So you're looking for how the questions
co-vary across large numbers of people.
So let's say here's a stupid example,
but it's.
It's really,
it's really straightforward,
easy to understand.
I might say,
how often do you smile?
One to seven.
How often are you happy?
Well,
what you'd find obviously is that people
who tended to answer that they smiled a
lot,
would also tend to answer that they were
happy a lot and so smiling and happy are
not exactly the same thing,
which is why we have two different
phrases to describe them,
but they're close enough so that they
seem to be reflective of some underlying
structure,
and so that's what factor analysis does,
is it allows you to take a large set of
questions to administer it to a large
number of people and then to
statistically analyze it.
Looking how the questions relate to one
another across the entire group so that
you can infer what the underlying
structure is.
And here,
here's the question.
In some sense,
if I ask you 100 questions,
how many questions am I really asking
you?
Because you might say,
well,
are you do you smile a lot?
Are you happy?
Do you wake up eager to start the day?
You say,
well,
is that one question asked three ways,
or is it three separate questions?
And the answer is,
well,
if the answer's reliably co-vary,
then it's reflection of an underlying
single dimension.
Now obviously those questions are
slightly different now,
but they'll relate to one another
sustainably.
And so you can infer out the central
stable factors.
Now it might be the case that.
So here's,
here's an example,
because you might ask how many stable
underlying dimensions are there?
In any set of questions,
if I ask you questions that relate to
your capacity to manipulate
abstractions,
all find that there's one factor.
So imagine you had an infinite library
of problem solving questions.
Doesn't matter what they are.
Capital of Georgia.
Here's the sequence,
two,
four,
six,
eight,
10.
What's the next number?
Here's five patterns.
Here's and,
and they,
they transform predictably across the
pattern array.
Here's five alternatives that the next
pattern might be.
Pick that one here.
Here's 10 words,
tell me what they mean.
Anything like that.
Here's a mathematical operation
computed,
anything like that.
Imagine you had a very large library of
questions like that.
Okay?
And Infinite Library.
And you took random sets of 100
questions from that library and you gave
that those cassettes to a thousand
people.
What you'd find was that people who and
the score,
so you gave them a hundred questions and
then you summed across all the items to
see how well they did.
What you'd find was that people who did
very well on one set of items would do
very well on another set of items and
very well have another set of items.
And that would be the same for people
who did badly if they did badly on any
one of the sets of randomly chosen items
of abstraction.
They do badly on the rest.
That's basically Iq.
That's all there is to it.
So it.
What Iq does is correct that for age.
But other than that,
that's all there is to it.
And the thing that's interesting about
those random sets of abstract problem
solving questions is there's one
dimension,
that's it.
Intelligence has one dimension,
and it's one of the most terrifying
statistics that are known to social
scientists.
And Iq is an extraordinarily powerful
predictor of longterm success,
especially in complex jobs.
And the reason for that,
it's quite straightforward.
Most complex jobs throw random sets of
complex problems at you.
That's what that's,
that's their definition.
So for example,
if you're working as a lawyer on complex
on complex court cases,
you have to be able to read very
quickly.
You have to be able to abstract,
you have to be able to problem solve,
you have to be able to formulate
arguments,
and you have to do that repeatedly in
different ways across very large spans
of time.
And so the fact that your ability to
solve any set of random problems is a
really good predictor of your ability to
solve any set of random legal problems.
It's more or less self evident that that
would be the case,
but the but the thing is the thing that
makes Iq so damn powerful and it's one
of the personality traits,
roughly speaking,
the thing that makes Iq so powerful is
you can basically get a decent measure
of it in 20 minutes.
It's very terrifying.
Anyways,
we'll go into ICU and some depths as we
progress through the course,
but you get one dimension out of out of
factor analysis of Iq.
Now in the personality domain,
we're using descriptive items.
You don't.
You get five dimensions and so,
so and you and what are these dimensions
exactly while you could think about them
as I think of them as sub personalities,
but here's some other ways of thinking
about them because we want to flesh this
out a little bit.
You can think of them as a frame of
reference so that if you're an
extrovert,
and I was going to tell you the
extroverted question,
does being around groups of people make
you energetic or does it exhaust you and
if you're the sort of person that will
go to a party and interact with 20
people in,
then you have to go home and be by
yourself for like two weeks.
Then you're introverted.
Introverts are exhausted by social
interactions.
Extroverts are the opposite.
They all,
they're,
they're energized by social interactions
and you know,
you might be in the middle so that you
can take it or leave it with regards to
social interactions,
but you're happy to go to them and
you're happy to spend time by yourself,
but a real extrovert,
there'll be some of you in here.
How many of you can't stand spending
time alone?
Okay,
so there's only two that will admit it.
Extroverts are more likely to admit that
sort of thing too,
by the way.
But then how many of you you like to
spend time alone or would rather be
alone?
Okay,
so there is a preponderance of
introverts in this class is by,
by,
by all appearances,
but that's a really,
that's a pretty canonical question for,
for extroversion versus introversion.
It's a very stable trait by the way.
It manifests itself early in life and
it's stable across the age span,
not completely.
Introverts can learn to be extroverted.
Extroverts can learn to spend time on
their own.
I think that actually your capacity to
expand your ability past the initial
constraints of your biological
temperament is something like the
development of character or wisdom you
know,
so if you're an introvert by nature and
you learn how to be extroverted,
then that expands your domain of
competence and if you're extroverted and
you learn to be introverted,
the same thing,
but it's almost like imagine a
distribution of extrovert,
introversion here,
extroversion here,
a normal distribution you're set when
you're young.
It's somewhere along that distribution
with some range around it.
And I think what you do as you mature,
if you develop your skills as you expand
that range,
but you're set,
the place at which you're set doesn't
move that much.
So okay,
so there's.
So you can think about them as
subpersonalities.
You can think about them as frames of
reference.
So frame of reference would be something
like,
well,
since you're extroverted,
you value being with people and so
you're going to look at the world.
For example,
if you're extroverted,
you come into a room like this,
you think,
oh look,
it's a whole field of opportunity for
social interactions,
and if you're introverted you think,
well maybe I'll go sit up in the corner
and hope everybody leaves me the hell
alone,
but so,
so it's an a priority set of perceptual
structures that you bring to bear on a
whole sequence of,
of,
uh,
environment.
So for example,
maybe you're high in openness versus low
in openness.
That's the creativity dimension.
People are high in openness,
tend to be artists and entrepreneurs and
open people will look at other people as
opportunities to engage in interesting
intellectual conversations.
And so you can tell when you're talking
to someone's old,
someone opened,
especially if they're very high in
openness because they're going to want
to talk to you about ideas or about
aesthetics.
That's what it's going to go right away.
So that's how they view you as a source
of that sort of conversation.
That's how they view the landscape.
Someone who's high in neuroticism,
which is a negative emotion dimension,
is more likely to view the world as a
place of threats to be,
to be protected against because they're
more anxious and more prone to emotional
pain.
Uh,
so anyway,
so,
so that's the frame of reference issue.
So there's,
there's something about your,
under an underlying fundamental
psychological traits that determine or
influenced at least your value
structures.
And they,
they do it at the level of perception.
They also tend to set your goals.
So extroverted people have as one goal,
the opportunity to engage with other
people.
So extroverts love parties,
they live for parties,
they love to tell jokes as well.
It's a very good behavioral marker of
extraversion.
And so they,
they,
because they value those sorts of
things,
they set them as goals in their life or
you could say the extroversion operating
within them sets them as goals within
their life,
depending on how deterministic you want
to be about it.
So,
um,
there their patterns of behavior,
that's another,
at a micro level,
you know,
I showed you that sort of hierarchy of,
of,
of value slash frames of references that
ranged from micro-behaviors up to high
order abstractions.
You can extract out a personality from,
by looking at people's micro actions as
well.
And one of the papers that I want you
guys to read that's on the course
website has to do with our investigation
into behavioral markers of the big five
traits.
Yep.
Maybe I don't,
we don't know exactly.
I'll get back to that at the moment.
That's kind of what it looks like is
that introversion is something like the
absence of extroversion.
But let me explain extraversion more
particularly and it'll make more sense.
Okay.
All right.
So you can think about them as stable
motivation.
So pro,
for example,
people who hired agreeableness,
I can generally tell people who are high
in agreeableness when they come into my
clinical practice and I start asking
them about their biography because my
experience has been that people who are
agreeable will tell you their biography
defined by relationships they've had
over their life.
So agreeable people are high and
compassion and high end politeness.
It looks like the maternal dimension,
it looks like the pair bonding
dimension,
something like that,
and so agreeable people tend to
characterize their lives in terms of the
intimate relationships they've had and
so those are also people who would value
an intimate relationship over anything
else.
If agreeableness is the uppermost trait
that characterizes their personality,
then well systems of values,
we already talked about that a little
bit.
The higher you are at a given trait,
the more you value certain opportunities
that are associated with that trait and
so I think it's worthwhile thinking
about traits along using all of those
different conceptual schemes to
understand what constitutes a trait,
but
what people are in some sense is a
little melody of traits.
Melody,
not m,
a l,
a d,
y,
although some people are like that,
but melody like a song,
you know where were different amounts of
each of the canonical traits operate to
a different degree at each person and
the person that manifest themselves as
the is the is the is the panoply of
those traits as they manifest themselves
in the world and so it's actually very
useful to understand your,
your big five traits as far as I'm
concerned.
Actually,
that's why I have you do that exercise
that you're supposed to do for this
class that helps you.
You identify your faults and virtues and
I used big five terminology to help you
do that.
So I'm part of the reason it's useful to
know what your traits are is because it
can help you figure out how you should
orient your life.
So for example,
if you're a hired extroversion,
you know you've.
You've got a proclivity towards sales
for example,
and you're gonna like you're gonna like
occupations where you have a lot of
opportunity for social interactions and
social networking.
You're not going to be happy if your job
requires you to sit alone by,
you know,
for,
for extended periods of time and work in
the absence of social interaction.
You're going to be one of those annoying
people then in one of those offices that
instead of sitting alone in their
offices,
going from doorway to doorway,
engaging everyone in conversation,
right?
So and you want to be in a position that
capitalizes on your traits because it's
really difficult to work contrary to
your traits.
The other thing that's worth thinking
about too,
and we're actually building a computer
app for this,
which is about which has been about 80
percent done for a whole year.
We've got a hypothesis that we're still
working out that's supported to some
degree by the relevant literature.
So imagine that you're looking for a
stable partner,
right?
So you might think,
well,
what do you want in a stable partner?
And at least in principle,
one of the things you don't want is too
much mismatch between you and that
person on the five fundamental dementia.
So for example,
if you're really extroverted and you
have a really introverted partner,
you're going to engage in continual
conflict about how much social activity
the two of you should,
should be,
should,
should what subject yourself to.
And it's very,
very difficult for people who broadly
differ widely differ on those dimensions
to come to consensus because it's not
just a matter of opinion,
right?
It's really a matter of different.
If you're looking at extremes of really
different types of people,
and the thing about introverts is they
just don't enjoy large scale social
interaction.
That much one on one,
they're often fine,
but in a group they don't like that and
they.
It tires them out.
Whereas a real extrovert,
it's like you isolate them and and they
just wither on the vine because a huge
part of what actually motivates them in
a positive way is tangled up with social
interaction.
And so if you're an agreeable person and
you have a particularly disagreeable
partner,
you're also going to run into problems
because the agreeable person will say
whatever you want,
whenever and the agreeable per a
disagreeable person will say,
well,
I'd like to know what the hell you want
for a change and be much more harsh and
much more demanding in this situation,
and the agreeable person is going to
find the disagreeable person harsh and
unpleasant,
and the disagreeable person is going to
find the agreeable person wishy washy
and unable to stand up for themselves.
And again,
that's a,
that's actually one of the primary
sources of tension between men and women
because women tend to be higher in
agreeableness than men.
It's about half a standard deviation,
which is quite,
quite,
uh,
quite a,
quite a large difference by
psychological standards.
And so what that means,
I probably haven't got this statistic
quite right,
but I think I've got it about right.
What that means fundamentally,
just so you have some sense of how large
a fact that is,
is that if you have a group of men and
women and you pick out random pairs,
the woman is going to be more agreeable
than the man 60 percent of the time,
so that's not an overwhelming
proportion,
but it's reliable and it's quite.
It's quite large by psychological
standards,
so there's the problem with
agreeableness with conscientiousness.
Well,
if you're conscientious,
you're industrious and orderly and
orderly.
People seem to be sensitive to
discussed,
which is something we'll talk about in
detail later.
We've had a hard time specifying exactly
what makes industrious people
industrious because it's hard to come up
with an animal model for that sort of
thing and there's no theoretical model,
but our latest idea is that it's not my
idea.
It's actually the idea of my graduate
student,
Christine Brophy,
is that industrious.
People find it
unpleasant and unsettling to to not be
doing something so it isn't so much that
industriousness makes them happy or
fills them with positive emotion.
That would be more extroversion,
right?
Because extroversion is the positive
emotion dimension.
It's an industrious.
People can't stand sitting around doing
nothing and you know,
this is speculation,
but human beings are obviously always
engaged in the exchange of labor,
especially the reciprocal exchange of
labor.
And you can imagine that in a in a
community where everyone knows everyone,
the people who work hard are going to be
pretty irritated on a fairly chronic
basis with the people who are completely
unproductive.
And my suspicions are that plenty of
people who were completely unproductive
in the history of,
of our,
of the evolution of our species were
wiped out by people who were unhappy
with their lack of productivity.
And so I think generally speaking,
human beings have this sense of ethical
obligation with regards to one another
to share labor.
And people who are conscientious really,
really feel that so they feel bad if
they're not busily working on something
that's productive all the time.
And so the advantage to being with
someone conscientious is,
well,
they're going to work like mad.
But the disadvantages,
So you know,
if you're looking for a partner that you
want to relax with or have fun with or
who isn't uptight,
then a conscientious person is probably
not a very good choice.
On the other hand,
if you're a conscientious person and
you're living with someone who's really
unconscientious,
that's good because they might be able
to help you relax,
but you're not going to be happy with
them because they don't work nearly as
hard as you do.
But even worse on the orderly dimension,
you know,
some of you have had roommates and maybe
you're more orderly than your roommate.
What does it mean?
It means you're annoyed by mess before
they are and you don't have to be
annoyed by mess much before you're less
orderly roommate for you to be the one
that's always running around picking
things up.
And so actually one of the things that's
emerged from the psychometric analysis
is that women are slightly more orderly
than men.
And I suspect that has something to do
with Un.
What would you call it?
Inequitable distribution of housework.
Because even if you're imagine that your
proclivity is to be triggered by
disorder 25 seconds before your
partners,
well you're going to end up.
It doesn't take much difference for you
to be the one that's always concerned
about the mess first.
So anyways.
And so if you're a really orderly person
and you live with a disorderly person,
well good luck getting along with them.
They're going to regard you as like
uptight and,
and over concerned with details and,
and,
and well and unwilling to relax.
That's for sure.
And they're are going to regard you as
well.
Just a bloody mess.
And how can anyone possibly live with
someone like you.
And so,
so another reason why it's useful to
understand your personality is because I
think it gives you a better crack at
finding someone that you can actually
live with over the long run.
And we don't know what the optimal.
I don't think you want to live with
someone who is exactly like you because
then both of you have the same strengths
and weaknesses and there's a bit of a
problem there,
right?
Because maybe an agreeable person can
use a bit of disagreeable person around
them to balance each other out and vice
versa.
Right?
So we don't understand the optimal
balance for,
for,
for longterm thriving in a relationship.
But I think we do understand the fact
that if you're too different in your
traits,
that those where you're different is
going to constitute a chronic source of
conflict.
So,
so anyways,
so you can think about that.
So.
Alright.
So how have psychologists studied
personality?
Well,
I'm going to talk most about the
statistical psychometric approach to
begin with,
but there are other approaches that we
will talk about as well.
So,
um,
let me give you some let,
let me give you the background on the
self report.
Um,
methodology first because it's really
formed the back bone of,
of psychological research into
personality.
So imagine that you took a comprehensive
sample of all the descriptive adjectives
in the English language.
Now,
it's trickier than you think because
actually what constitutes an adjective
isn't that easy to determine because
many words have forms that are
adjective,
verb,
and Noun,
depending on how their.
How the same word is written out,
so distinguishing adjectives from verbs
or adverbs turns out to be more
difficult than you might think,
but let's just say for the sake of
argument that you could collect all of
the descriptive adjectives in the
English language and that then perhaps
you decided because you don't want to
use all of them,
you decided that you were going to use
the most common thousand of them and
there are tables that enable,
enable you to look up the frequency of
words.
And it turns out that in common
parlance,
it's like five percent of the vocabulary
of English language accounts for 95
percent of the usage.
It's an example of this phenomena called
the burrito distribution,
which we'll talk about later.
So in fact,
most discourse has done with 500 words.
You can get about 80 percent.
Something like that of speech in terms
of single word comprehension with 500
words.
So let's say you took the thousand,
you took all the descriptive adjectives
and then you took the ones that were the
most common thousand.
And so here's the hypothesis,
hypothesis part,
and this is a critical thing to know.
This is called the linguistic
hypothesis.
The linguistic hypothesis is that
variation in personality among human
beings is of sufficient import so that
it's become accurately coded in the
lexicon.
So what that means is that roughly
speaking,
is that over the course of the evolution
or evolution of any language,
we use English as the example here,
descriptive terms have been generated
that actually do cover the variation in
personality and that essentially cover
them without bias.
Now that's a hypothesis.
Actually.
It's an axiom.
It's because the hypothesis is in some
sense isn't.
It's not exactly testable.
We'll leave that aside for now.
It's testable a little bit,
but not,
not easily.
So.
So that's the first thing you have to
accept.
You have to accept that it's possible to
extract out what constitutes personality
by looking at the linguistic
representation of descriptors in so far
as they're encapsulated in language.
Okay?
So when,
when people talk about trait models,
like the big five being comprehensive
representations of personality,
that that isn't exactly what they mean
and you need to know this,
what they mean is that it's a
comprehensive representation of
personality in so far as personality has
been encapsulated in language.
There may be elements of personality
that we haven't been able to talk about
or we don't know how to talk about that
are of crucial importance and there may
not be,
but the big five theorists assume that
there aren't.
All right?
So,
so that's,
that's,
that's a limitation of the theory.
But if you accept that,
then you say,
well,
the first thing you want to do is take a
relatively random cross section of the
descriptive terms because then you don't
introduce bias into the initial stages
of the inquiry.
So Matt,
I'll tell you something that we did
recently and you can tell me what you
think about its analogous.
We're trying to study political
correctness.
And so what the first thing we're trying
to figure out was,
is there even such a thing?
Because if you,
if you look at the political dialogue,
what you find is that people on the side
of the political spectrum who have been
defined as politically correct tend to
say that it doesn't exist and that
category is just a pejorative term that
was invented by people who hold
alternative political opinions.
And so the first question is,
well,
what do you mean some does it exist?
What do you mean by exist?
What?
How do you tell if a psychological
concept is real?
Like his anger is anger or something
that exists objectively.
Is it done an objective phenomena?
Well,
it's not that easy to,
to determine.
You say,
well we,
we act like it is and we understand what
anger means if but no one goes around in
the world and says anger without saying
anything else or you'd run away from
them.
You know what they do is they,
they,
they placed the word anger into a
sentence and place the sentence within a
conversation and they enable you to
infer exactly what they mean by the word
anger,
by listening to the surrounding context.
Right?
And if you're going to turn that into
something like an objective term,
what you do is you pull out the term
anger and then you make the hypothesis
that it represents something real in the
objective world.
But it's not that easy to determine if
something does exist,
especially if it's a psychological
phenomena in the real world.
What do you mean by exist?
That's the problem of construct
validation.
Okay,
so that's another term you really need
to know if you're interested in
experimental psychology,
especially on the personality and a
construct is a representation of
something psychological that
hypothetically exists.
Objectively,
how do you establish its existence
objectively?
Well,
does fear exist?
Now you have the problem with all the
emotional terms.
Does joy exist to surprise exist?
Does embarrassment exists?
Does guilt exist?
Shame?
How are they related to one of their
guilt and shame,
for example,
seem quite similar to one another.
Right?
And pain and fear and anger all seem to
share the,
the,
the attribute of unpleasant and negative
emotions.
And so how similar,
how something.
If something exists,
it should be the same as some things and
different from other things,
and that's part of construct validation
as well to specify how the construct is
the same as some things and different
from others.
Anger should be reliably distinguishable
from joy,
for example,
because otherwise they're not different
and anger and fear should be somewhat
the same if they're both negative
emotions.
So it's extraordinarily complex to to,
to validate a construct.
And so here,
here's what we did with political
correctness and it's.
The reason I'm using the political
examples is because that's an obvious
place where self serving bias can enter
the scientific arena.
Right?
So if I wanted to make a point about
political correctness or if I wanted to
make a point about rightwing fascism,
I could build my biases into the
measurement instruments accidentally and
then they would produce as output,
what I put into them as input.
And I want to protect myself against
that if I actually want to do this
scientific investigation properly.
So what we did when we started to
construct our measures of political
correctness was getting employee a
number of people to go through as many
news sources as they could get their
hands on to identify any attitude or
behavior,
some roughly that that had been
described by anyone at all as
potentially politically correct.
So it was kind of agnostic and we're
trying to do it as randomly as possible,
you know,
to get as many new sources as we
possibly could so that we were sampling
across the environment without bias.
Okay.
So then we came up with,
I don't remember how many,
couple hundred,
maybe more a couple hundred items that
were roughly indicative of what you
might describe as political correctness,
but that's not good enough,
right?
Because just because you have this
random assemblage of items doesn't
indicate at all that they're all
measuring something that was similar,
but that's just implicit.
They're all called political
correctness,
but you don't know if those attitudes
covariant.
What that means is if you held one
attitude of that list,
were you more likely to hold another or
multiple others?
Right.
So is the conditional probability of
holding multiple items.
Is there a high probability of holding
true multiple items simultaneously while
you figure that out with factor
analysis?
So what we did is we turned that into a
questionnaire using different question
types and we administered it to several
hundred people and we did a factor
analysis and we found actually that
there was such a thing as political
correctness because the questions
clumped together,
people would reliably answered them in a
pattern manner,
but that there were actually two
dimensions that were quite separate.
So there isn't one political
correctness,
there seems to be two.
And then we looked at the personality
predictors in the ICU predictors in a
variety of other predictors that would
enable us to come to some understanding
of the temperamental proclivity towards
those political attitudes,
if any.
We knew already that
political conservatives tended to be low
in trait openness.
That's the creativity dimension and high
in trait conscientiousness.
Whereas political liberals tended to be
high in trait,
openness and low in conscientiousness.
And so one of the things that's
extraordinarily interesting to know from
the big five perspective is that your
political proclivities are very
powerfully influenced by your
temperament.
And so one of the things you can think
about with regards to ongoing political
discussions in the real world is that
those discussions are actually attempts
by people of different temperament.
One,
to impose their temperamental viewpoints
on the world and to to engage in a
dialogue with people who are actually
quite different than they are.
So like conscientious people like they,
they value hard work,
rules,
order
reliability,
integrity and structure.
And so their dutiful.
We analyze what predicted military
performance.
For example,
in theU ,
s army overwhelmingly conscientiousness.
It's not surprising,
right?
Because it's a very structured rule,
ordered top down,
a follow procedure sort of endeavor.
Now the armed forces had problems with
that to some degree because they were
also simultaneously looking for people
who could think independently on their
feet.
Because if you're in a battlefield,
for example,
especially if you're isolated from your
command structure,
there's gonna be times when you have to
make extraordinarily difficult decisions
on your own.
But if you're selected primarily for
conscientiousness,
that's not going to be your forte
because if you're a conscientious
person,
what happens is that you enter into a
contract with someone,
even yourself,
and then you carry it out.
So now we've also spent a lot of time
selecting entrepreneurs.
I work with this company in California
that has started schools for
entrepreneurs in 100 and now I think 160
different countries all over the world.
This the guy who started this,
whose name is Dale Resi,
he's a real.
He's an absolute monster.
The guy started,
well,
he started all those schools in five
years,
165 schools in all,
all across the world,
eight different languages and we've been
screening people for entrepreneurial
ability and if you're going to be an
entrepreneur,
you almost have the opposite profile.
As a soldier.
You're very high in openness and you're
lowering conscientiousness or at least
conscientiousness is irrelevant.
And the reason for that seems to be that
like if you're an orderly person and
you'd like to follow procedures and
rules,
it's kind of hard for you to start a
company because when you first start a
company or engage in any other creative
process,
because entrepreneurs turn out to be the
same as artists,
you kind of have to.
You're not operating within a rural
governance structure.
In fact,
there may be many times where you have
to break a small rule to to move
properly at a higher level of analysis.
There's no algorithmic way of generating
a new company,
right?
Obviously.
And so it's people who are very high in
openness,
who happened to be good entrepreneurs.
And so this is something I thought was
extraordinarily cool because we'd.
We'd also already known what predicts
managerial,
administrative and academic ability and
Iq is crucial for any complex jobs.
So we'll just leave that behind.
But what predicts academic ability,
for example at the University of Toronto
is in intelligence obviously,
but also conscientiousness.
The correlation between creativity and
grades at the UFT is zero.
Zero.
Right?
But it's not.
It's not surprising that the thing is
that you know,
it's easy to be cynical about that,
but one of the things you have to
understand about creative people is that
they continually step outside of the
domain of evaluation structures,
right?
Because if you're going to say you're
going to evaluate the performance of 100
professors on their lecturing ability,
while you kind of have to measure what's
common across all the professors in
order to come up with the standards for
evaluation,
well that means you're not going to be
able to use that structure to evaluate a
particularly creative professor because
he or she is going to do something in a
way that's so different that it won't
show up on the evaluation measure and
that of course that's what happens in
universities.
You know,
somebody sent me a couple of days ago,
somebody sent me an essay that they had
written for their master's thesis that
was wildly creative and they were
basically told to leave the program and
that they couldn't continue.
Not in a mean way.
They.
What happened was that what they were
thinking was so outside of the
conventions in the discipline is that no
one had any idea what to do with the
essay,
so then that's really the law of
creative people,
right?
They're always stepping outside of
evaluation structures and so it's not
that surprising that relationship
between creativity and grades at the u
of t is zero.
We found out as well by looking at
graduate student performance across
multiple institutions that there was a
negative correlation between creativity
and graduate school performance.
It wasn't even zero.
It was worse than negative.
Being creative was negative and you
think,
well that could make you cynical as
well,
but.
But you can't be cynical in that way
because one of the things that happens
in science is that science tends to
progress incrementally rather than in
great leaps now and then someone comes
along who blows the structure out of a
science advances at a ridiculously like
Einstein,
but like most people are nine style.
It may be thank God for that.
Most of the time you're in a discipline,
you,
you understand the discipline,
and then once you've developed
understanding of the discipline,
you know what the next micro question is
that should be answered and part of the
reason that science is so powerful is
because it allows people who aren't
genius level creatives to make real
advances in the generation of knowledge.
One tiny micro step at a time,
doesn't matter if there's 100,000 people
doing it and each of them is making a
micro step.
Man,
we're zipping along as fast as we
possibly wanted zip along,
and so it turns out to be
conscientiousness.
That's the excellent predictor of
graduate student performance.
That's the best predictor for law.
It's the best predictor for managerial
positions.
It's the best predictor for
administrative positions.
Anything that has a structure of rules
that needs to be applied.
Conscientiousness is a great predictor,
so but it's not good for predicting
artistic ability or entrepreneurial
ability and that's also really important
because one of the things.
This is partly why bureaucracies
stultify right?
Because what happens is they,
as they develop,
they get chock full of conscientious
people with a few psychopaths thrown in
there just for good measure.
They get chocked full of conscientious
people busily zooming,
efficiently down to a single track,
and then all of a sudden the landscape
shifts and they're going very,
very efficiently in exactly the wrong
direction and then the whole bloody
thing falls apart.
So you need to have some creative wing
knots in your organization to come up
with completely absurd ideas that might
just on the off chance be true.
And so creativity is strange in that
manner too.
Because it's a high risk,
high return game.
You're a lot safer in your life to find
a functioning entity and to operate as a
cog within it,
as long as the entity keeps functioning.
Because if you're creative and you go
off on tangents all the time,
there's some probability that one of
those tangents is going to be exactly
what is needed at the time and you're
going to become hyper successful as a
consequence.
But there's much more probability that
even though your.
Some of your ideas might be highly
valuable,
the probability that this is the right
time and place for them is
extraordinarily low,
so to produce a successful creative
product,
for example,
in the marketplace,
you need a ridiculous combination of
creativity so that you keep generating
ideas and then a network around you of
people who have skills that you don't
and then the production of a of a
product,
let's say whatever that happens to be,
that's actually in demand by the
marketplace at exactly that moment and
that someone else hasn't already done
better.
So the sensible thing to tell anybody
who wants to be creative is that stupid.
You shouldn't do it.
It's,
it's your probability of success is so
low that it's better just to do
something sensible.
But the problem with that is that
creative people can't do that because
they're creative and if they shut down
their creativity,
it's like an extrovert who's gone to
live in a,
in an isolated cell,
a creative person who isn't being
creative,
they just,
they just wither and die.
So they're stuck with it.
So.
But it is a high risk,
high return strategy.
So probably better if you want to be
creative or if you are and you should
take this advice to heart because I'd
been watching people for a long time.
If you want to engage in a creative
pursuit,
you should find something stable to do
that will generate you an income and you
should pursue the thing that you're
creative about on the side because
monetizing creative production is so
bloody difficult that especially now
like especially in like artistic
domains,
generation of music and that sort of
thing.
It's like you just have no idea how many
million songs there are on the Internet
and the vast majority of them
commercially available get downloaded
zero times,
like 80 per,
I think there's 80 million songs or
something like that on the net and I
believe it's something in the
neighborhood of 70 million get
downloaded zero times and then there's
100 that can get downloaded like $350
million times.
And so those people are wildly
successful and everyone else collapses
in failure.
Yep.
No,
we'll talk about that more.
Okay.
So that's not a bad overview for,
for initial foray into psychometrics.